AND GROUPTHINK.
HAVE A WONDERFUL NIGHT.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BREAKING NEWS FROM THE DOJ'S
POLITICAL WITCH HUNT AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP INCLUDING A
SHOCKING REPORT ABOUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S INVOLVEMENT IN
THE RATE AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE KNEW MORE
THAN THEY LET ON.
THEY PREVIOUSLY DENIED IT.
AFTER LYING TO AMERICANS ABOUT
GAIN-OF-FUNCTION RESEARCH, THE
ORIGINS OF COVID-19 AND MASKS
AND VACCINES AND PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING ELSE.
DR. FLIP-FLOP FAUCI IS JUMPING
SHIP AND WE ARE GOING TO TELL
YOU WHY FAUCI'S POWER TRIP IS
FINALLY COMING TO AN END.
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, JARED KUSHNER,
A RARE INTERVIEW.
HE WILL JOIN US AND GIVE US THE
BEHIND-THE-SCENES OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
FIRST I HAVE A MESSAGE TONIGHT
FOR THE VERY LAZY BERNIE SANDERS
LOVING SOCIALIST TRUST FUND BABY
BRETT IN A HOODIE THAT'S RUNNING
AS A DEMOCRAT FOR THE SENATE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
RECENTLY HE HAD A FEW CHOICE
WORDS FOR YOURS TRULY.
HE IS TRYING TO RAISE MONEY OFF
MY NAME.
"IT BRINGS ME NO PLEASURE TO ASK
BUT ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH A HOST
OF A LITTLE SHOW ON FOX NEWS
NAME SEAN HANNITY?"
IT'S ACTUALLY CALLED "HANNITY."
TALKING ABOUT DR. MINUTE OZ AND
ACCUSED US OF SPREADING DS LIES.
WE DON'T LIE ON THE SHOW.
HE ASKED SUPPORTERS, PLEASE CHIP
IN AT LEAST 25 BUCKS, 50 BOOKS,
100 BOOKS BECAUSE "WE HAVE TO
COUNTER SEAN HANNITY WITH AS
MUCH GRASSROOTS SUPPORT AS
POSSIBLE.
THIS BERNIE LOVING SPOILED TRUST
FUND BABY BRETT WHO IS UPSET
NEEDS YOUR MONEY DESPERATELY
BECAUSE I TOLD THE TRUTH ABOUT
HIS POSITIONS, LET'S SEE,
LEGALIZING DRUGS, FRACKING,
BELIEVING IN SANCTUARY CITIES
AND STATES.
GETTING VIOLENT CRIMINALS OUT OF
JAIL.
ABORTION UP UNTIL THE MOMENT OF
BIRTH, NO RESTRICTIONS
WHATSOEVER.
SO INSTEAD OF ACCUSING ME OF
LYING, WHICH WE DIDN'T DO, JOHN
NEEDS TO QUIT HIS WHINING,
STOPPED HIS CRYING, MAN UP AND
PUT ON HIS HOODIE, DEFEND HIS
RADICAL OPINIONS.
JOAN, SHOW ME WHERE YOU THINK I
LIED.
STOP HIDING BEHIND YOUR
SUPPORTERS AND BEGGING THEM FOR
MONEY.
TRYING TO RAISE MONEY OFF MY
NAME.
COUNTER ME YOURSELF.
YOU CAN HAVE THE WHOLE HOUR, ONE
ALONG WITH ME ON THIS PROGRAM IF
YOU WANT.
I WILL EVEN THROW IN AN EXTRA
THREE HOURS OF MY RADIO SHOW ON
OVER 700 STATIONS.
COME ON IN.
WE ARE READY.
MAN UP, STOP WHINING, COME ON
THE SHOW.
SHOULDN'T BE A PROBLEM FOR JOHN.
HE CLAIMS TO BE A TOUGH, RUGGED
CHAMPION OF THE WORKING MAN.
HE HAS GOT THE GOATEE, HE WEARS
HIS HOODIE WHEREVER HE GOES.
HE LIKES TO ROLL UP HIS SLEEVES
AND SHOW OFF THE TATTOOS.
HE IS A SELF-MADE INDIVIDUAL
FIGHTING FOR WHAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT HE WOULD HAVE YOU
BELIEVE.
HERE'S THE REALITY.
IT'S ALL A SHOW.
IT'S ONE BIG GIANT FARCE.
JOHN FADIMAN GREW UP EXTREMELY
WEALTHY.
GREW UP IN AN AFFLUENT SUBURB OF
YORK, PENNSYLVANIA, BASEMENT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME IN
COLLEGE ESPECIALLY, WELL, VERY
EXPENSIVE SCHOOLS AND I'M SURE
DADDY PAID FOR.
HE DOESN'T REALLY HAVE MUCH WORK
EXPERIENCE.
HIS 13 YEARS AS MAYOR OF A TINY
LITTLE TOWN OF BRADDOCK WAS
PART-TIME, SEMIVOLUNTEER
POSITION.
HE PAID 150 BOOKS A YEAR.
UNTIL THE AGE OF 49, MR. HOODIE
JOHN FADIMAN RELIED ON MOMMY AND
DADDY TO PAY FOR HIS WEED OR
WHATEVER ELSE HE WANTED.
A YEARLY SALARY CAME FROM DADDY
AND A FREE HOUSE FROM HIS
SISTER.
HIS SISTER SOLD HIM A HOUSE FOR
A DOLLAR.
DR. ROSS PAID FOR ALL THE HOUSES
HE LIVES IN BY WORKING HARD BIKE
MOST PEOPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA SO
MAY, NO MISTAKE, THERE'S NOTHING
RUGGED ABOUT JOHN FEDERMAN.
IN MAY, THE 53-YEAR-OLD DID
SUFFER FROM A DEBILITATING
STROKE.
HE IS UNABLE TO ATTEND HIS
PRIMARY NIGHT VICTORY PARTY.
HE HASN'T BEEN PHYSICALLY OR
MENTALLY ABLE TO CAMPAIGN UNTIL
RECENTLY.
A SHORT AND RARE A CAMPAIGN STOP
IN PENNSYLVANIA, ALL OF
11 MINUTES, JOHN FETTERMAN
STRUGGLE TO, AND CAN'T EVEN A
LITTLE BIT.
>> WEEK COULD AFFECT ANY PART OF
PENNSYLVANIA WHERE WE ARE GOING
TO START, THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL IS
STARTING.
TWO YEARS AGO I WAS TALKING TO
THE MEDIA SAYING DO YOU WANT TO
KNOW WAS GOING TO BE THE NEXT
PRESIDENT?
YOU KNOW WHAT I SENT?
I SAID TELL ME ONE THING.
TELL ME WHO WINS THEORY.
25 OF THOSE COUNTIES.
54 RED COUNTIES.
MORE VOTES, MORE VOTES THAN
DR. OZ AND THOSE COUNTIES AS
WELL.
I GIVE AWAY LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR IN
PENNSYLVANIA THE ONLY LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR IN HISTORY TO DO THAT.
YOU CAN COUNT ON US.
TO ELIMINATE THE FILIBUSTER.
ELIMINATE THE FILIBUSTER AND
LET'S GET SOME STUFF DONE FOR
AMERICA.
>> Sean: JOHN FETTERMAN
CLEARLY IS STRUGGLING.
IN ALL SINCERITY, I HOPE HE GETS
WELL BUT HE'S NOT FIT TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA.
FAR MORE DISTURBING ARE HIS
INSANE POSITIONS IN A NUMBER OF
KEY ISSUES AND IS ALWAYS BEING
HIDDEN BY THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
MOB.
HERE IS FETTERMAN'S POSITION ON
OIL AND GAS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS, ESPECIALLY
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS TO
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> SOMETHING THAT HAS TO
EVENTUALLY GO AWAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT
TRANSITION OUT.
NOW YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
VISITING THAT AND MAKING
DECISIVE ACTIONS LIKE CANCELING
THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE WHICH SOME
PEOPLE DON'T SUPPORT.
I THINK HE MADE THE RIGHT CALL.
>> Sean: MR. HOODIE, NO
FRACKING, NO PIPELINES, NO OIL,
NO GAS.
IT'S A $80 MILLION INDUSTRY.
THOUSANDS OF HIGH PAYING CAREER
JOBS IN THE ENERGY SECTOR.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE USED TO NOT
WORKING.
MOST PEOPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA WORK
HARD AND JOHN FETTERMAN WANTS TO
PUT THESE PEOPLE OUT OF WORK AND
OUT OF BUSINESS.
THAT WOULD SEND THE ENTIRE STATE
OF PENNSYLVANIA'S ECONOMY INTO
AN ALL-OUT TAILSPIN.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
IT GETS WORSE.
HERE IS JOHN FETTERMAN'S
POSITION ON VIOLENT CRIME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WAS ON A PANEL.
HE SAID WE COULD REDUCE OUR
PRISON POPULATION BY A THIRD AND
NOT MAKE ANYONE LESS SAFE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT'S A PROFOUND STATEMENT.
>> Sean: IT'S ALSO PROFOUND.
VIOLENT CRIMES IN MANY CITIES IN
PENNSYLVANIA WENT UP 60% AS HE
WAS THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE WANTS TO
RELEASE THOUSANDS OF VIOLENT
FELONS BACK ON THE STREET.
IT'S NOT JUST RHETORIC.
DURING HIS TIME AS
PENNSYLVANIA'S LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR HE TRIED TO FREE SCORES
OF VIOLENT CRIMINALS INCLUDING
ONE CONVICTED MURDERER WHO
ROBBED AND KILLED AN 18-YEAR-OLD
GIRL IN ORDER TO HAVE BUY
HEROINE.
DO YOU WANT THAT IN
PENNSYLVANIA?
BY THE WAY, JOHN FETTERMAN ALSO
WANTS TO MAKE HEROIN LEGAL AND
ACCESSIBLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
YOU WANT TO LEGALIZE HEROIN.
WHY ARE YOU TALKING?
WHY DO YOU CARE ABOUT THESE
THINGS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE AS
SOCIETY HAVE THE OPTIONS ON THE
TABLE, INCLUDING NEEDLE EXCHANGE
WHICH IS ONLY TECHNICALLY LEGAL
IN PHILADELPHIA AND PITTSBURGH.
EVEN SAFE INJECTION SITES BEING
CONSIDERED LIKE IN PHILADELPHIA.
>> Sean: JOHN FETTERMAN
DOESN'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF MUCH OF
ANYTHING.
MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE HE WAS
HANDED EVERYTHING IN LIFE ON A
SILVER PLATTER.
NATURALLY HE FEELS A SPECIAL
BOND WITH MULTIMILLIONAIRE
SOCIALISTS, HIS COMRADE IN ARMS,
BERNIE SANDERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THAT'S MY AM PROUD TO ANDRAS
BERNIE SANDERS TODAY.
BERNIE SANDERS AND I AGREE THAT
A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO THIS COUNTRY'S
FUTURE.
WHETHER IT'S IMMIGRATION,
WHETHER IT'S MARIJUANA
LEGALIZATION, WHETHER IT'S
UNIVERSAL PRE-K OR AFFORDABILITY
COLLEGE EDUCATION.
WE STAND TOGETHER AS THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE CANDIDATES IN OUR
RESPECTIVE RACES.
IT'S MY PLEASURE AND PRIVILEGE
TO STAND WITH BERNIE AND HAVE
BERNIE'S BACK.
>> Sean: WHAT BERNIE WANTS TO
DO FOR THE U.S., I WANT TO DO IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
HE GOT A HEAD START IS THE
MIRROR OF BRADDOCK WERE UNDER
HIS LEADERSHIP VIOLENT CRIME
WENT UP.
THE POPULATION WENT DOWN FROM
WELL OVER 2,000 RESIDENTS TO
LESS THAN 1800.
AT ONE POINT FETTERMAN HIMSELF
WAS SO FEARFUL OF CRIME IN
BRADDOCK, GUESS WHAT, HE CHASES
AFTER A COMPLETELY INNOCENT
AFRICAN AMERICAN JOGGER, HOW
THIS MAN AT GUNPOINT BECAUSE
FETTERMAN BELIEVES THE MAN WAS
INVOLVED IN A RECENT SHOOTING
WITH NO ACTUAL REASON
WHATSOEVER.
I THOUGHT LIBERALS WERE AGAINST
THAT KIND OF RACIAL PROFILING.
IMAGINE IF THAT WAS A
REPUBLICAN, THE OUTRAGE FROM THE
MEDIA MOB WOULD BE NONSTOP BUT I
DIGRESS.
GOOD NEWS TONIGHT ACCORDING TO
RECENT POLLS, THIS RACE IS
TIGHTENING VERY QUICKLY.
DR. OZ CAN DEFINITELY WIN
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE PEOPLE OF
PENNSYLVANIA LEARN ABOUT THE
PHONY HOODIE STORY IN THE RECORD
OF THIS GUY, JOHN FETTERMAN.
SO IF IF YOU'RE UNEASY ABOUT
LIVING AMONG VIOLENT MURDERERS
OR YOU CARE ABOUT YOUR JOB OR
YOUR BUSINESSES AND YOU DON'T
THINK SOCIALISM UNDER JOE BIDEN
IS WORKING, GET TO THE POLLS AND
VOTE ON NOVEMBER 8.
AS FOR MR. FETTERMAN,
MR. BERNIE SANDERS LOVER, TRUST
FUND BABY BRAT WHO NEVER HAD A
REAL JOB AND ONLY CAMPAIGN FOR
11 WHOPPING MINUTES, I WISH YOU
WELL WITH YOUR HEALTH.
STRONG ENOUGH TO DEFEND ANY OF
THESE POSITIONS, YOU ARE WELCOME
ON THIS PROGRAM ANY NIGHT.
COME ON, MR. BERNIE SANDERS AND
A HOODIE.
SHOW ME